what's up everybody i'm david and
welcome back to tasty's quarantine chef
challenge now on our first challenge we
saw kelly and her adorable little boys
take first place with that delicious
chicken pot pie bake with the cheddar
biscuits so much so that we're gonna
have her come back another time and show
us how to make a hamburger helper from
scratch but for right now amanda and
betsy are going to go head to head in a
pecan pie recipe bake off now i want to
see some paella pecans in that thing
okay i need pecans in every bite but i
need all of you to once again stay tuned
till the end and let me know in the
comments which recipe looks better hey
tasty fam i'm betsy
i am based in hermosa beach california
today i'm gonna be making my
grandmother's
southern pecan pie
but with a twist
because i don't have
some of the ingredients
[Music]
hi my name is amanda i'm from los
angeles california and today i'll be
making chocolate pecan pie
i've got two cups of flour in the bowl
right now i'm just gonna add a little
pinch of salt 10 tablespoons of butter
and now for the fun part basically i
just want to break up the butter pieces
and work them into
the flour so now i am going to add in 1
tablespoon of ice water at a time oh
yeah here we go guys
here we go i think that looks good
what do you think
okay so i'm going to start by adding the
salt granulated sugar two and a half
cups of ap flour i've never put cinnamon
in a pie crust
we are experimenting in the time of
quarantine
and now i'm going to add the butter
chunks okay
[Music]
and i'm going to bake this at 375 for 25
minutes and then i'm going to remove the
bake the weights and the foil and bake
it for another five to ten minutes so to
crimp the edges of our pie all you need
is a knuckle and then a thumb and index
finger and you're kind of just pressing
into
each of them like so almost like
pinching
we're now gonna add in our sugar all
right gammy she clearly had a sweet
tooth i see where i got it from we are
going to be substituting
corn syrup for honey
i feel like this one is not normal honey
um
but we're just gonna work with it
vanilla extract
but i'm gonna also add in just a pinch
of salt all right we're gonna stir these
guys together
i'm now gonna beat three eggs and i'm
gonna add it to our honey vanilla
mixture
we are going to add in our filling now
we're going to move on to
the topping here we have crushed
pretzels melted unsalted butter and two
tablespoons of more sugar let's tap the
pie
[Music]
so i'm gonna start by melting the six
tablespoons of butter and two ounces of
semi-sweet chocolate i'm gonna do 250
grams of corn syrup four eggs half cup
of brown sugar a tablespoon of cocoa
powder quarter teaspoon of salt two
tablespoons of bourbon and i'm going to
whisk all those together and i'm gonna
add my chocolate and butter mixture that
we made on the stove and a little splash
of vanilla the zest of like half the
cara car orange maybe a third cup of
chopped pecans so i'm going to grab the
pie bring it over scrape this filling in
now i'm going to actually top it with
some of these pretty guys
and that is our filling
all right we're gonna take the pie out
of the oven using my
trusty
oven mitt that's my husband
look at that
it's pie time
time to give it a go
oh my god
i like did something cool
it's almost like a salted caramel pie
with added crunch the topping is almost
like a brittle have you ever transformed
a family recipe and made it your own
let us know in the comments i'm
certainly curious
kudos to you
sending all the positive vibes
or in my case positive pies
your way thanks for watching and thanks
for joining me on this journey
oh wow wow wow
there she is
[Music]
crust is nice and crispy
oh yeah there she is basking in the
sunlight so that is how you make my
chocolate pecan pie i hope you enjoyed
watching i had a really good time baking
and stay safe out there
now those pies look fire you got to
sound off in the comments and let me
know which one you'd rather make right
now is it betsy's crushed pretzel pecan
pie or amanda's chocolate pecan pie i'm
david and as always i'll see you next
time
oh yes
[Music]
you